[Music]
i hope
he will definitely stay humble as he is
right now
which is something really good and not
really easy to do when you have a lot of
fame you know
to some he's the greatest counter-strike
player in the world continuing to try
and find more ground
continuing to try to find out from the
flames you can burn the man alive but
he's burnt around to a crisp
as saiwu has to shine through in a
one-on-two he's got the first
second tie with
to others he's the savior his region has
been waiting for
well they're anticipating banana from
the looks of the guy over here
that rings out first he's had enough
he's gonna keep going through it he
doesn't really care about it
again get him out of here
he's the closer but to everyone else
he's simply known
as zion so i'm on a few words what have
you got to say about winning this game
no no no
i love it consistent you can't
so who is this 19 year old phenom and
how did he skyrocket to superstardom in
the span of literally
one year well as it turns out some of
the hype surrounding this prodigious
up-and-comer
has a lot to do with his nationality it
has to do
with the fact that he's french of all
the regions to ever clash in the arena
of counter-strike
none are as stubborn as insular and as
downright
infantile as the french so french cs can
be described
in two different ways on one hand you
have some of the greatest gods to play
the game right shocks
kenny s scream and on paper they have
some of the best players
in the world on the other hand you also
have a group of divas who for some
reason just
can't get along and it's always been
this way
for nearly a decade france and belgium
stood atop the world of competitive
counter-strike
despite arriving onto the scene rather
late the release of source called the
region to action like never before
by 2007 they'd earned their first world
championship in 1.6
and by the turn of the decade had
created some of source's biggest stars
[Music]
come the much anticipated release of cs
go in 2012
french cs had started to solidify itself
as a world
power soon shocks and kenny s two of the
region's source prodigies had taken the
new game by storm
let's finish off in comes kenny s oh my
god
kenny s with three insane kills
and he has time wait are you telling me
he's gonna win the round has he got time
yeah he's got time unbelievable by 2014
the happy lead ldlc had earned france
their inaugural major win
this is all on get right i might be the
perfect man to have left here
trying to walk in pacing himself he's
going to spot nbk first he goes
ldlc they pick it up and look at that
they can hardly believe it
they're hugging each other and it must
be an unreal sensation
and the crowd will stand up and
recognize
ldlc in their performance
and by 2015 kenny arguably the greatest
player ever to touch the game up to that
point
led his region to a much anticipated
repeat
so could happy going for an aggressive
peak sure why not seized is gone now
four players remain here for navi and
they're going to be pressing on to this
site and
it's an ideal situation for them but mbk
removes zeus and it's not looking good
oh and a second headshot there flamie
going to be going kirshy man
enemy winning the last major 2015 and
the second title narrowly ever for three
of these players the first property
and apex what a victory to outsiders it
seemed like the french scene was a force
to be reckoned with
a wellspring of wild and explosive
talent the only issue was everything
happening behind the scenes
[Music]
over time the french rosters became
notorious for their infighting
and internal disputes despite being
world-class competitors
it seemed as if they were constantly
engaged in a never-ending sea of
squabbles
grudges and blood feuds there was a
negative riot but they there was a
problem in the team where
sharks just wanted to take leadership
and
as a team we all agreed that it was
something needed to make a big change in
the team so we changed
like scrambled all our city positions uh
sharks made
his calls on the t side and it went well
online we had some pretty good results
we managed to qualify
uh for esa we were winning games
so it was okay but on the long term
sadly
shock couldn't work as a new game leader
because um
it's going to be all very much dependent
on his form and if his thoughts going
down
he's going to bring the whole team with
him so it's something that we
couldn't get on the long term it didn't
take long for the scene to start rotting
from the inside out
god knows they had all the ingredients
for a super team several of them
probably
but since they refused to go
international and so and so wouldn't
play with so and so
well the scene remained maddeningly
stagnant
by the time the french orchestrated
their third major shuffle in early 2017
it felt as if it were all too little too
late yeah so that super team didn't
really pan out at all despite kenny s
and shocks being on the same team
two of the greatest french players to
ever do it they just weren't able to
turn on
at the same time when the team finally
broke up
in 2018 it kind of just cemented the
fact that the french at this point were
just
stubborn slowly but surely this storied
region
sank into darkness disrepute and despair
the consensus was that thanks to their
squabbling the french had squandered
their time in the sun
by 2018 happy's awe-inducing ace screams
mythical one taps and kenny's literal
godhood were nothing but distant
memories
french cs was dead and it would take
nothing short of a
miracle to bring it back to life the
kind of chosen one prophecy you would
find in an anime
and lo and behold that's exactly what it
got
so in 2018 french cs was arguably at its
worst
ever in cs go they failed to do anything
at the majors and they didn't really
have a good year
yet while all of this was happening
there would these small murmurings from
reddit
to face it of this young french kid who
was just dumming people online
his name was zywoo and people were kind
of pointing out that he might just be
the savior of french cs now as it turns
out
matu zaiwu herbal has been involved with
counter-strike for a lot longer than you
might think
you might even say it was meant to be
[Music]
was born on november 9 2000 the same day
that counter-strike
saw its commercial release whether fate
or coincidence
it's led the community to bestow the
phenomenal frenchman with a very special
title
the chosen one it's fitting since zyru
isn't like other superstars it didn't
take him years of grinding to make a
name for himself
crack into the top tier and convince the
community that he could dominate
it was clear from the get-go that this
kid
was born to play c.s
by the tail end of 2016 he tried his
hand at the qualifiers for both ecs
season 2's developmental league
and dreamhack masters las vegas before
finishing fourth in the esl major winter
league
in the new year he had a brief stint on
ecorp before joining y6
sure zywoo holds on to the a bomb site
but he's gonna get pinched
he's still able to take two kills to his
name maybe a third as he sees the head
of zeus
the flashbang in his pocket but he
doesn't even need it
just one after another gambit toppled
towards the site
and it's back to the man advantage for
y6 to hang on to
can they seal this out because it would
be a great look for them moving forward
even pulling the crossfire as well
adrian wants to commit towards the safe
side he's going to be in a world of hurt
with so
under the balcony holding the angle he's
spotted but he's going to get the frag
anyway
over the course of 2017 zymo began to
amass something of a cult following
his eye-popping performances even earned
him a trial run in face it pro league
at just 16 he'd caught the attention of
several
important figures in the french
community and was already regarded as a
legend in the making
this kid was almost too good naturally
people started to speculate
as to whether he was legit one thing you
guys should know is he's aware of where
everyone is for sure this guy is using
wall hacks online look at the third kill
he pulls out flash and sees that the guy
is already out instant pre-fire
that literally explained this guy the
issue was that since he'd yet to finish
high school
xy's mother encouraged him to defer his
professional debut
until he completed his studies even as
teams became more and more interested in
signing him
zyru chose to heed the advice of his
mother and wait
in late 2017 the stack with which he was
playing got picked up by against all
authority
and under that banner the french phenom
bided his time
conjuring up frags that caused the tier
1 orgs awaiting his coming of age
to salivate
[Music]
and then in october of 2018 zawu finally
decided
on the org with which he take
counter-strike by storm
team vitality and i saw friends
energy wisdom hope
and diligence my family now
look people expected xaiwa to be great
that he'd at least wake his region
up from its unfortunate slumber what
they didn't expect
is that he'd become a world-class
superstar in a matter of months
it's thailand who's already here
charging on in and oh he's gonna find
himself a third
youngster the new boy off the block
[Applause]
after winning his first land at
dreamhack open atlanta 2018
zairu entered 2019 as one of the hottest
players in the game
but he was also among the shyest and
most subdued prospects
cs had ever seen and zyru what is it
like being in front of this
amazing crowd i don't know you don't
know okay
great stuff we're gonna head back over
to you guys despite failing to make top
eight at his first major in ketovice
his rating and repute continued to
skyrocket
for mars against five sets of ak is
vitality
looking to make it an eleven or four
half a joe they're trying to recover at
five as
i would just melt straight through two
here on the b bombs like fair attacked
upside who finishes off a 3k
for him no damage done to the vitality
side awp therefore taken outside who's
going ham
and there's nothing ago could do to stop
it on for the ace by cs summit 4 he was
making top tier rosters
look like silvers it is xy after all
he's got 100 hp
ultimately but he has a glock and he's
pretty close up so
let's see that's the first kill oh my
god
he's gonna find that flank he's looking
he's got one hp
he's got one ap he can push and get it
he's playing with the headshot angle
there's a chance here
oh my god henry
he's taking his headset off he's
standing up i mean he's hand over mouth
he's about to leave
but it was at none other than esl one
cologne the cathedral of counter-strike
that zaiwu
came alive in a big way by the end of
groups it had become apparent that
this shy reserved giggly little french
kid could actually be
the single greatest counter-strike
player in the world
reclaim the advantages though it's
vitality have got a player towards top
connector at sidewalk
on the other end of it is crims in the
corner at this point
you're always palace crimson's got a
peak oh what is that that is just
unbelievable oh my god this game is
crazy
in with another shot this man is
delivering for vitality
into the three kills to proland and zai
will eventually
drop him on the floor but it has to be
the one before clutch from zaire
nearly comes in barely enough health to
survive here on broadland but xavier
wants to kill there's the head shot
pulls it back
and the opposite side who's got the
triple krimz is the last man standing
and there's time for the defuse
cyber wants to smoke the bomb if you're
crips you have to be scared
and zygo wins it that is unbelievable
from the young frenchman
oh no the bomb plan it might be right in
front oh my god
he lines it up and shuts it down and now
we just need to wait
they can't find the bomb anymore terry i
think
oh he does get it in the last possible
second
and cyber is back for more looking for
him
already with the triple just needs one
more click of that scope and
target is hiding behind tetra side
windows he's got to back one kills
winning it for vitality you've never
seen anything like him
despite losing the grand finals to team
liquid it felt as if cologne was zyewu's
real rise to greatness
naturally it didn't take long for the
community to start pitting him against
the game's
current king simple the thing is despite
being neck and neck in terms of stats
xaiwu's playstyle was actually a lot
different from simples
he was equally talented to be sure but
he didn't flaunt the same kind of cocky
aggressive
and in your face play style do you like
being compared
or you are and you and
don't compare zairu and simple i don't
really care about that
[Music]
i don't like it i don't care because i
am
simple so i doing my things with my team
and
that's it unlike simple zairu didn't
habitually defy the physics of
counter-strike
why because he didn't have to he has
this uncanny ability to make consummate
professionals
look like gold nova scrubs alex brought
down to 20 hp and zywoo is gonna have a
fighting retreat but he's even worried
about the flank he knows that astralis
has been working this map
so well there's one shot vegas not going
to be able to punish him good
follow up from zai wu but they're still
searching and he's got another that's
three kills in the run he can go for
this
he can go for this so much i don't think
he's going to win it oh
astralis over extend and xaiwu has
pulled something out of nowhere
way too early to commit that many
resources that many players to the hunt
oh it's so ridiculous
especially the way that he finishes it
one tap
now you might be thinking what exactly
makes him so good
it's pretty straightforward actually if
you appeared on his screen
you died that's it he always killed you
it was as if he knew where you were
before you did as if his brain
had wall hacks i was one of the first
guys thinking that he was cheating like
when we
because i used to play him back in the
lower tier of our scene
and it's not until you actually play
with him and speak to him that you
understand that
the guy just doesn't see things the same
way as we do you just
i could like imagine in his brain it's
just like the matrix so you've got
numbers coming down like
okay he was here at one point so he
could be here here here
and then he just checks those two angles
and he's in one of them and he kills
them that's how that's how it feels
from cologne on vitality solidified
themselves as true
top tier contenders with zyru becoming
more unbelievable by the day
he carried his team to top four finishes
at iem chicago
dreamhack malmo and iem beijing before
closing the deal
at epicenter different roles that can be
played with it certainly smokes that
comes to mind could flash into the
apartment xaiwu
does get one back mp9 he's gonna be so
careful because the aks are rapping but
he was aware of it and muric
didn't look in the right direction that
gives him a headshot an ak to play with
should he like to
go for it but he's just going to farm
cash at this point in time which is
great for the offer
history even works at that range i was
on for a great start
holding from a long should have a pretty
good chance but he gets caught with
awkward timing now he's trapped in the
corner might need assistance but the
flash is good sigh woo
keeps on going makes it a third on the
round easy
shut down from zai wu 10-0 and we're on
round number four
and simon's gonna clutch this one versus
three on the side with the creek
rattling off some shots of the player a
mini pit he gets the quick
kill two more players against him and
zai wu keeps on going
into the 1v1 s attack's been good so far
in this game but saiwu goes back
to the or rounding the corner going for
the fight and zai wu
is showing up here on inferno he may
have been quiet on vertigo but this man
is not going to be quiet in back-to-back
maps
only waksik has a defused kit there's
just no way
surely there's no way just down to walk
sick now he's the only man standing
vitality have done it they've broken the
streak and they've taken moscow
and the epicenter championship 2019.
having secured his first premier
tournament victory and sitting literally
0.01 higher than simple in terms of
rating on lan
the community speculated that the french
phenom was a shoe-in
for the top spot on hltv's fame top 20.
i hope i will be top one but if i'm not
it's good but
it's good he was i think zai was a
little bit better than than simple in
this year
i think both teams uh didn't win as much
as astralis for example as liquid so
it's quite hard to
really take in account the trophies they
lift so only talking about individual
performance i think both are pretty
close but i would still go with the
averages here if you could do it a
little bit better
but it remains to be seen whether zyru
has what it takes to take the mantle
away from simple
simple's been on top for nearly twice as
long with arguably
less help you don't actually think
zero's better than you no i i don't
think
so i mean individual no no yeah okay 100
it also remains to be seen whether
vitality will be able to succeed as a
team cs go is more competitive now than
it's ever been
and if zyru is to spearhead his region's
long-awaited return to form
he'll need to do more than perform
individually
still there's no denying the french
fragger's incomprehensible explosiveness
if anyone has what it takes to dethrone
arguably the greatest player of all time
and rescue french cs from the doldrums
it is
zywu now whether he does or not well
we'll just have to wait and see but man
is he off to a great start
and he's got support all around him back
up in the hands of hunter is good for
two and it is
vitality falling being unraveled at the
seams
so it seems until xiwu will be
attempting this clutch
1v2 and an excellent deagle head shot
it's just hunter up
the spam shots are there but still both
players stand and it's around the corner
that saiwu will take it
oh man uh future best player in the
world if he isn't already
and uh yeah he's just a monster so
that's pretty much it
for watching if you want more content
like this hit the sub button and ring
that notification bell
for unique bite size videos you won't
find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages
you